il est fait il est 7h il est
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce sujet mon
âme d'artiste de avec les yeux de
Morgane un sujet autour de l'art celui
qui impressionne souvent qui intrigue
toujours et qui peut également faire
rêver alors comment vivre ses rêves tout
en les partageant avec les autres la
réponse au fil du sujet
[Musique]
tout de suite le reportage de TV7 8 et
on retrouve les invités en plateau juste
après
je crois qu'il est plus par là ouais
c'est ça
et le tien il est plus derrière ou plus
de vent dernière mise en place avant la
répétition générale pour Fanny cette
comédienne plaisiroise de 28 ans a
intégrer le théâtre Eurydice en janvier
2019 cet établissement et service d'aide
par le travail basé à plaisir en gage
des comédiens en situation de handicap
depuis 1986 un travail rémunéré attend
plein pour cette troupe de 9 comédiens
on a beaucoup de chance du coup parce
que tous les artistes ne peuvent pas se
vanter d'avoir un spectacle permanent
comme ça la plupart sont intermittents
et doivent chercher encore et encore
donc je pense qu'on a beaucoup de bol
fanny a commencé le théâtre à l'âge de 6
ans lors d'une représentation d'une
pièce de William Shakespeare en classe
de CP sa mère était fascinée par ses
capacités de mémorisation elle a obtenu
une licence d'études théâtrale à la
Sorbonne Nouvelle allez allez cultiver
allez à un niveau intellectuel hors
normes
très agréable de travailler avec elle je
fais ça pour pouvoir m'amuser tous les
jours et honnêtement bah je ris tous les
jours donc je pense que je vais avoir
une bonne santé grâce à ça la troupe
repecte actuellement le spectacle
heureusement que vous êtes là mise en
scène par Cécile tournesol et écrit par
Roland Dubillard acrobate du verbe et
jongleur de mots se retrouvent sous un
chapiteau de fin du monde échange entre
ces deux clowns très bavards
pour une fois que je gagne Fanny elle
est très impressionnante elle a des
capacités incroyables de de mémoire ce
qui est surtout aussi
formidable c'est qu'elle a une passion
pour le théâtre et donc voilà on sent
qu'elle est heureuse sur scène je
ressens tout mon corps je ressens tout
ce qu'il y a autour de moi je ressens le
public et et il y a quelque chose où
quand je suis sur scène je me sens
vivante la troupe joue actuellement 3
spectacle la pièce heureusement que vous
êtes là sera représenté les 16 et 17
décembre au Théâtre Eurydice de plaisir
[Musique]
Pascal et Sabine bonjour à vous bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être là pour ce sujet
mon âme d'artiste Sabine vous êtes
directrice artistique de la compagnie
les toupies qui œuvrent pour la mixité
des personnes valides et en situation de
handicap c'est bien ça parfait et Pascal
nous nous sommes rencontrés sur un salon
métier et handicap et vous vous êtes
ferronnier d'art
très bien et sur vos métiers respectifs
donc on va peut-être commencer par vous
pour l'instant Pascal comment vous en
êtes arrivé à ce très très beau métier
d'art j'y suis arrivé parce que j'ai
fait de la théorie pendant 40 ans et du
coup pour des problèmes de santé je suis
obligé d'arrêter tout complètement et du
coup je me fais une reconversion
en ferronnerie d'art et en taillé en
gris coutellerie
et qu'est-ce qui vous a entre guillemets
inspiré motivé pour aller vers ce métier
peut-être qui peut être assez
impressionnant
oui bah c'est de créer de créer des des
choses en métal des œuvres que je
réalise il faut dessiner il faut il faut
avoir l'aspiration
c'est devenu comme ça il y a longtemps
que je voulais faire ça mais bon c'était
un rêve mais le rêve s'est réalisé
un rêve comme point de départ ça c'est
plutôt joli et Sabine de même pour vous
comment est-ce que vous êtes devenu
directrice artistique
les choses se font chemin faisant je
dirais
j'étais d'abord comédienne
voilà j'ai depuis toute petite j'étais
un peu baignée dans dans
cette univers c'est univers avec un papa
professeur de littérature qui
connaissait des tas de poèmes par cœur
qui m'a emmené conservatoire quand
j'étais adolescente et puis ensuite
voilà donc j'étais d'abord comédienne et
puis il se trouve aussi que j'ai
des personnes en situation de handicap
dans ma famille d'accord et à un moment
donné dans ma vie de comédienne
c'est est venu ce mêler cette question
du handicap et cette question de d'avoir
envie de jouer
puisque j'ai pas trop pu jouer avec mon
petit frère quand on était enfant et
envie de partager cet espace de la scène
où on joue ensemble de partager avec des
personnes en situation de handicap
et oui justement
le rapport entre
l'art et le handicap lequel est-il ou
comment on crée comment l'art peut
servir entre guillemets même si ça enfin
voilà c'est pas forcément utilitaire là
mais comment peut-il servir un petit peu
la cause de la solidarité du vivre
ensemble etc
trop grande question mais
l'espace de la de la scène c'est c'est
un outil magnifique de liberté et
d'affranchissement je dirais comment il
m'a
dans ma vie ça va ça a été vraiment ça
m'a sauvé la vie je dirais voilà et dans
cet espace là on a des contraintes bien
évidemment mais une liberté dans ces
contraintes
qui font que plein de choses peuvent
être explorées peuvent être
prises en compte les accidents les
incidents deviennent des chemins qui
s'ouvrent des gens qui s'ouvrent et
tout simplement
tout un chacun avec ou sans handicap
parce que évidemment derrière le la
personne handicapée il y a d'abord une
personne donc tout un chacun a un
potentiel infini de créativité et on le
voit avec Pascal il y a la et ça que
chacun puisse trouver son domaine et
l'espace de la scène c'est un espace où
on est ensemble où on crée ensemble et
c'est un espace de de d'épanouissement
extraordinaire alors c'est parfait
Sabine vous avez donné le faut que
j'allais employer par la suite et vous
avez fait la transition
parce qu'elle pour reprendre ce mot
d'épanouissement déjà est-ce que ça vous
parle cette notion d'épanouissement dans
votre métier
et qu'est-ce que ça vous a apporté en
fait ce métier en terme de découverte
ferme la découverte beaucoup de choses
comme les bokets que Sabine
elle a presque elle a presque tout dit
parce que ouais quoi ce mot vous voyez
que je dis c'est elle l'a dit avec les
mots que moi je prends le témoin mais la
liberté imaginez la liberté qu'on a quoi
par rapport à avant où j'étais dans ce
cercle vous pouvez pas vous pouvez pas
sortir c'est et après tout s'ouvre enfin
tout s'ouvre devant vous que vous
je vais parler comme je le sens mais
vous voyez le papillon
vous voyez le papillon vous voyez la
libellule vous voyez petit escargot vous
voyez les oiseaux vous avez le temps de
tout voir c'est
beaucoup plus d'émerveillement et de
liberté
je crée je vois j'ai créé des papillons
j'ai créé des libellules bon grâce à ma
femme parce que m'a dit tu mais je les
ai vu je les ai vu à côté de mon atelier
dans mon jardin et tout ça donc j'ai
j'ai
recréé à la forge en ferronnerie ce que
j'ai vu
cette libelli ce petit Jon dans la mare
à côté de chez moi je la vision je la
recrée et au final
la beauté qui est simple c'est dans la
simplicité qui fait que ce que je
ressens et dans votre métier pour ceux
qui ne connaissent peut-être pas ce
qu'est le métier de ferronnier comment
vous pourriez le définir quelque part
ou qu'est-ce qui me enfin qu'est-ce qui
vous paraît artistique pour ceux qui ne
connaissent vraiment pas ce qu'est la
ferronnerie puisque la ferronnerie donc
on a fait déjà
déjà qu'est-ce que j'ai choisi déjà la
ferronderie c'est que moi le but c'est
que je prends je vais créer dans des
barres de 6 mètres de long que l'acier
des fois pour mettre à mon compte j'ai
récupéré cette année d'acier l'acier la
plus de il a plus de 100 ans déjà donc
tu as quelque chose de fort pour moi à
travailler à travailler il travaille
très bien avec la maîtrise du feu parce
qu'il faut chauffer une certaine couleur
pour pour créer ce que j'ai créé
les volutes les petits choses comme la
petite chaise que je fais pour les
petits enfants les petits fils petits
garçons et c'est la maîtrise du fort
avec l'enclume le marteau et avec avec
ses aciers je pense dans des barres de 6
mètres je fais pas de récupération c'est
vraiment
dedans quoi vraiment plusieurs
possibilités notion elle travaille de
plusieurs éléments OK et
Sabine de votre côté quels sont les
spécificités peut-être du monde du
théâtre
comment ça se passe parce que là on
vient un peu d'échanger sur la
ferronnerie et quels sont les enfin les
choses qui vous parlent les choses que
les gens ne connaissent pas peut-être
sur une représentation de théâtre alors
on se fait souvent une idée du théâtre
qui peut être faussée par les
expériences qu'on a eu à l'école ou
alors évidemment le théâtre c'est un
genre littéraire mais ce n'est pas que
ça pour moi le théâtre il commence dès
que un être humain raconte une histoire
à d'autres êtres humains on est déjà
dans le théâtre et ça peut être dans la
rue ça peut être dans une école ça peut
être dans un théâtre ça peut être ça
peut être partout en fait et cette
histoire elle peut se raconter avec un
texte qui a déjà été écrit mais elle
peut se faire aussi en direct en
improvisant elle peut se faire sans mot
simplement par la présence du corps et
voilà elle peut se faire de en dansant
elle peut se faire en chantant elle peut
se faire de plein de manières
différentes donc dans notre approche
parce que je suis pas toute seule dans
la compagnie on est toute une équipe et
quand on œuvre avec des personnes qui
ont des des spécificités des difficultés
particulières alors on ne s'attache pas
à la comment dire on ne s'attache pas la
pathologie ou handicap voilà on
s'intéresse à la personne encore une
fois et on avance ensemble on improvise
on lance des thèmes et on avance au fur
et à mesure c'est pour ça que je disais
ces chemins faisant que on
va se donner un thème on va se donner on
va dire tiens et si on faisait ça et
puis j'observe je vois ce qui est
possible ce qu'il est moins et puis on
adapte on s'adapte tout le temps tout le
temps et au fur et à mesure la chose
elle elle apparaît mais elle est pas
j'arrive pas avec une pièce en disant
toi tu vas jouer ça toi tu vas jouer ça
et tu fais trois pas et voilà on n'est
pas dans
on est dans l'écoute de ce qui est et
comment ça va se révéler
et là avec les groupes qu'on a c'est
pareil comment ça se révèle et nous le
boulot c'est de créer les conditions
de sécurité de confiance de
bienveillance où les gens se sentent à
l'aise et où sont pas obligés comme
souvent dans le quotidien
d'être des super héros du handicap des
super héros bien propre bien bien droit
bien voilà non on laisse le costume
social à la porte et là c'est l'être
l'enfant qui va qui va jouer avec les
autres et on revient vraiment cette
histoire de liberté et de créativité qui
prend tout son sens effectivement et
vous m'aviez parlé aussi du fait de
décloisonner est-ce que ça rejoint ce
mot que vous avez employé en parlant
justement du monde du théâtre est-ce que
ça permet juste effectivement d'abolir
certaines frontières quelque part
c'est notre c'est notre objectif en tout
cas c'est que puisse se rencontrer des
mondes qui se rencontrent pas à des
personnes âgées avec des enfants des
personnes
avec
sourde avec des personnes non voyantes
des personnes avec handicap psychiques
des voilà que les gens puissent se
côtoyer et se rencontrer en tant qu'être
humain sur l'essentiel et pas sur ah il
est comme si il est comme ça mais je
vais pas savoir faire oui mais moi ça me
met trop
si ça non arrêtez là on a plus le temps
de ça là il y a une urgence à à
réhabiliter l'être humain comme dit
comme dit vaclavavel qui est un grand
homme de théâtre il faut réhabiliter
l'être humain et on a plus faut y aller
là faut se connecter les uns aux autres
parce qu'il y a du boulot
vous êtes d'accord Pascal avec cette
idée que
c'est vrai c'est valable pour moi aussi
c'est la même chose ce que j'ai appris
ce qu'on m'a transmis il faut il faut le
transmettre alors j'ai un petit garçon
comme ça depuis des garçons
à l'adolescent comme après ça vient un
peu plus tard à 30 40 même 80 ans tout
ça j'ai toutes les personnes même des
femmes qui me demandent ouais j'aimerais
bien
enfin forgé même la ferronnerie ça peut
te les couteaux tout ça parce que
parce que c'est c'est pas dire fait Eric
si je peux le dire un peu comme ça c'est
pas trop d'explication c'est c'est pour
moi c'est c'est pas dire de c'est
magique c'est comme de la magie enfin
je passe piquer j'ai du mal à expliquer
les choses non mais c'est pas le
ressenti il est curieux
comment en tout cas dans nos deux
approches c'est ce rapport direct à la
matière en fait
concret charnel de tout l'être alors
Pascal avec le feu le fer et le et moi
avec la matière humaine en fait mais
c'est la même démarche
[Musique]
j'ai déjà fait des démonstrations de
forges en Eure-et-Loir j'ai fait la fête
des vendanges à Chartres au mois de
septembre
j'ai fait d'autres aussi démonstration
de force et peut-être en ferronnerie ou
coutellerie les gens ils ont jamais
vu ça comment comment je procède à vélo
avec l'eau tout ça parce que la personne
qui fait ça ça permet de faire découvrir
et donc ça permet de faire passer aussi
des messages un peu si je comprends bien
quelque part
et vous vous Sabine vous pensez que ça
peut permettre de transmettre des
valeurs ou des messages
c'est comme un parent
qui dit fait si fait ça si l'huile le
vit ça va être le meilleur exemple
plutôt que des paroles donc le message
je suis toujours un peu embêté je pense
que le fait que les gens voient sur
scène des personnes heureuses qui ont
laissé leur handicap à la porte
c'est l'exemple vivant qui est le
meilleur message et le meilleur meilleur
témoignage en fait
et
quels sont les témoignages justement des
personnes en situation de handicap avec
lesquels vous travaillez quelles sont
les choses qui ont pu vous marquer dans
les propos voilà qui sont qui sont plus
vous rapporter
alors souvent moi je travaille beaucoup
avec des gens qui ont handicap mental
donc pour qui le langage est pas
toujours aisé
mais ce que je constate c'est que il y a
par exemple un de nos comédiens que je
connais depuis qu'il a 14 ans et
maintenant il en a 40 donc cette
fidélité cette continuité ça prouve bien
qu'il y a quelque chose qui se passe
et on a il y a lui mais il y en a
d'autres aussi donc
s'ils y reviennent c'est que voilà il y
a une nourriture dans dans ce qu'on dans
ce qu'on propose dans les témoignages il
y a aussi
un jour un jeune homme qui travaillait
en ESAT et qui était très gentil très
poli toujours soumis toujours et un jour
il s'est mis en colère contre son
éducateur des actes parce que il voulait
le garder plus longtemps au travail et
ne pas le laisser venir à l'atelier et
il s'est mis en colère et ben tout d'un
coup quelqu'un qui tout d'un coup se
dresse et dit mais moi je m'affirme et
je suis pas d'accord avec ce que je suis
en train de subir et je et je décide
pour moi-même là je lui ai dit mais
bravo Nicolas
apprendre à dire non parce que ça nous
convient pas sinon on fait des gens qui
sont des moutons et qui sont tout le
temps dirigés par les autres et ils
peuvent pas prendre en main leur vie sur
scène je leur apprends vous oui non oui
non gardez leur fille et à s'affirmer
ça m'impressionne tant d'affirmation et
l'art peut permettre de s'émanciper
j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup l'idée
c'est très très joli
parce que
sur tout ce que permettent peut
permettre l'art il y a aussi la question
derrière peut-être de comment on peut y
accéder et je me demandais est-ce qu'il
y a des adaptations particulières
aujourd'hui qui vous aide à exercer
votre métier
oui bien sûr
je dis ça parce que il me semble me
rappeler que vous aviez parlé de
matériel un peu différent oui tout à
fait oui
j'étais reconnu juste une reconnaissance
handicapée par rapport à mon métier
forcément et du coup
je suis toujours en contact avec far 28
et que des fois j'ai besoin de d'être
subventionné pour du matériel pour que
ça m'aide par rapport à mon handicap à
l'atelier
et oui non mais c'est important de
rappeler qu'il existe effectivement des
solutions tout à fait et
justement à propos de ces de ces
solutions ou de ce que vous pourriez
vouloir dire est-ce que vous auriez
quelque chose à transmettre à une
personne en situation de handicap qui
n'oserait pas devenir peut-être une
personne artiste ou qui ne saurait pas
si elle peut se lancer dans le milieu
artistique vous aurez un message à
transmettre oui
ils vont prendre quoi
on peut
il y a pas de barrière si après c'est
mon expérience à moi personnelle si on
veut si on veut si on y met la tension
il faut le vouloir il faut y mettre ma
tension c'est comme la ferronnerie ou
les couteaux qu'on forge il faut y
mettre l'intention si vous les avez pas
l'intention la volonté il y a rien qui
se passe il faut le provoquer ça c'est
personnel c'est ressenti mais c'est
faisable il y a aucun problème suivant
les handicaps on peut surpasser les
choses c'est ce qui m'est arrivé donc
voilà bien sûr et avec de la volonté on
peut réaliser effectivement ses rêves
merci Pascal et peut-être un petit mot
pour conclure puisqu'on arrive bientôt à
la fin de l'émission
Sabine est-ce que vous aurez un message
ou quelque chose à dire sur la compagnie
les toupies pour finir
venez tenter l'expérience et autour de
chez vous il y a
même en milieu ordinaire des endroits où
vous pouvez pratiquer vous pouvez
essayer vous pouvez vous lancer dans
dans l'aventure et ça vaut le coup
vraiment ça vaut le coup et si on vous
dit non vous dites bah si
cette histoire de volonté après c'est
pas toujours voilà
faut se battre aussi les aidants et les
gens qui sont autour
doivent accompagner aussi ça
ensemble on peut peut-être y arriver on
repart sur cette idée effectivement de
m'écouter possible avec beaucoup de
volonté je vais finir là-dessus merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
témoigné vous avez apporté vraiment
plein d'informations et de notions
essentielles sur vos métiers respectifs
merci Pascal et merci Sabine merci
Morgane merci à vous on finit ce sujet
mon âme d'artiste un sujet tout en
émotion en rebondissements et en
aventure et surtout n'hésitez pas à
retrouver plus d'inclusions bien sûr sur
les réseaux sociaux de l'émission et je
vous dis à très bientôt avec les yeux de
Morgane
[Musique]